hello everyone my name is reto meier and
welcome to this week in Android
development November fifth 2012 last
week was a big week in Android with Andy
Rubin pulling back the veil of secrecy
to announce the release of Android
jellybean 4.2 along with a slew of new
hardware to go along with it it's now
possible to get a pure Android device to
suit all tastes with Nexus devices now
available in tall Grande and venti all
three sizes will be available for
purchase at Google Play on November 13
this week in Android developers live
Roman and Adam briefly considered
hosting Android design in action live
from New York underwater and without
power before coming to their senses in
heading home to brace for hurricane
sandy as a result there was no show but
I'm happy to report that all of our
presenters are safe and well it's
unlikely that the guys will be back in
action this weekend as New York
continues its cleanup efforts but as
soon as they're finished bailing out the
new york studio the guys will be back
meanwhile in sunny california where the
only way our studio will over be
underwater is when the next big
earthquake hits and tips us all off the
edge of the US and into the bottom of
the Pacific Ian and I were able to host
the first of our new format app clinics
we briefly considered following ABC
sitcom up all nights lead and switching
to a multi-camera live studio audience
format but instead elected to dedicate
the majority of the shoulder technical
tips and tricks that make great travel
assistance app last Friday we looked at
how to use location and transfer data
efficiently as well as sharing data
between apps you can tell us which apps
and which app categories you'd like us
to review using this Trello board we'd
prefer to review self nominated apps so
if you're an app developer please put
your app forward for us to take a look
at this weekend and I will be exploring
ways to work together more effectively
by eliminating the awkward face-to-face
meetings and corresponding only through
instant messengers find out more this
Friday when we look at the technology
behind whatsapp messenger groupme and
trillian tune in on Wednesday for our
regular European office hours with
Richard neck and watches Bruno hosts a
very special spanish edition of android
latam developers live next week also
sees the premiere of a new show table
flip with me rado Maya this week I'll be
talking about exit buttons and why you
should never ever have one in your
Android apps exit buttons not
and once as always you can find the
complete schedule for this week's live
shows at Google developers live if you'd
like to meet one of our developer
advocates in person and you're lucky
enough to live in Prague you can catch
richer Nick at the prior gdgd fest this
weekend today's live wallpaper was fresh
leaves from Maxwell's net and remember
to make the most of this night like
we're going to die young my name is reto
Meier thanks for watching